you have been known to on a rare
occasion play drunk
is there mathematical formula for
sort of on the x-axis how many drinks
you had and then the y-axis
your performance slash creativity is
there like an optimal for like uh one of
the would you suggest for the feeding
world championship that people would
be required to drink would that change
things in interesting ways yeah not at
all um
maybe for rapid but for for blitz i
think if you're playing blitz you're
mostly playing on
on short calculation and intuition and i
think
those are probably enhanced if you've
had
a little bit of a little bit to drink
can you uh explain the uh
the physiology of why that's why it's
enhanced or the you're just you're
thinking less you're more confident
oh yeah i think
i think it's just confidence i think
also like a lot of people
feel like they're better at
speaking languages for instance if
they've drunk a little bit it's just
like removing these barriers yeah i
think that it's it's a little bit of
the same in inches
in 2012 i played the world bliss
championship and
then i i was doing horribly for
for a long time i also had food
poisoning there i couldn't play at all
for for three days so there before the
last break i was like in the middle of
the pack like in
i don't know
20th place or something and so i decided
like
as the last last gasp i'm gonna go to
the mini bar and just have a few drinks
and
what happened is that i came back and i
was suddenly relaxed
and i was playing fast and i was playing
confidence and i thought i was playing
so well
i wasn't playing nearly as well as i
thought
but it still helped me like i won my
remaining eight games and if
there had been one more round i probably
would have won the whole thing but
finally i was i was second so generally
i wouldn't recommend that
but maybe as a last resort sometimes
like if you feel that you have the
ability like obviously none of this
is remotely relevant if you don't feel
like you have the ability to begin with
but if you like if you feel like you
have the ability there are just factors
that
make it impossible for you to um
to show it like numbing your mind a bit
can probably be a good thing yeah well
it's interesting
especially during training you have all
kinds of sports that have interacted
with a lot of athletes in grappling
sports
it's different when you train under
extreme exhaustion for example you start
becoming
you start to discover interesting things
you start being more creative yeah a lot
of people um
in at least in
brazilian jiu jitsu they'll they'll
smoke weed you know it does it creates
this kind of anxiety and relaxation that
kind of
enables that creative aspect it's
interesting for training of course you
can't rely on one of those things too
much but it's cool to throw in like a
few drinks every once in a while to uh
yeah one first of all to relax and have
fun and two to kind of try things
differently to unlock a different part
of your brain
you